Hello.
My name is Reto Meyer, and
welcome to a special extended
edition of "This Week in
Android Development,"
featuring What's New
in Android 4.3.
Last week was a big one for
Android with the release of
the newest model, Nexus 7.
Measuring almost two millimeters
thinner and 50
grams lighter than its
predecessor, it also features
surround sound 5.1, front and
rear facing cameras, a 1.5
gigahertz processor, 2 gigabytes
of memory, and a
1920 x 1200 resolution
display.
All this and it confers a plus
three to both public speaking
and asking out girls.
If your apps aren't optimized
for tablets, now's a good time
to get started.
But the real use for developers
is the release of
Android 4.3.
In addition to the inclusion
of even more butter, it
includes support for restricted
profiles, OpenGL ES
3.0, Bluetooth Low Energy, and
improvements to media,
accessibility, and performance
analysis.
Let's take a closer look at
some of these new APIs.
Restricted profiles builds on
the multi-user functionality
introduced in Android 4.1,
allowing you to create
subprofiles that include
system-wide and app-specific
restrictions.
That means your app can declare
restriction entries,
including Boolean flags,
choices, and multiselect
choices, like this single choice
restriction entry, each
of which can specify ways that
your app's functionality can
potentially be restricted.
Your app will then appear in
these system settings where
each of these restrictions you
defined will be available to
the device owner.
They can select their
preferences for your app for
each of their restricted
users.
To apply those preferences to
your app at run time, simply
check for a bundle of
restriction settings
associated with your app by
querying the user manager when
your app resumes, as shown
in this code snippet.
You can find out more about
supporting restricted profiles
from Rich Hyndman's DevByte.
Also new to Android 4.3 is
platform support for Bluetooth
Low Energy.
BLE support allows you to build
apps that interact with
the latest generation of small,
low power devices and
sensors that use Bluetooth's
smart technology to
communicate.
The BLE APIs use this
workflow to interact
with supported devices.
You start by scanning for nearby
devices, then manage
connections, discover available
services, and query
and monitor characteristics
provided by connected devices.
You start by scanning for BLE
devices calling start on the
scan on the phone's
Bluetooth adapter.
This scan results are reported
using this LeScanCallback
callback that reports any
detected devices, a received
signal strength indication,
and the advertisement data
describing the services
available from that device.
You can then connect to that
device, using its GAT server,
using the call connect GAT
method, implementing the
Bluetooth GAT callback to
receive connection results and
monitor the available services
and characteristics.
You can then read and write
those sensor values and
request notifications whenever
a particular
characteristic changes.
Your app can work as either a
client or a server and can
transmit and receive data
in either mode.
The API [? is a generic, ?] so
you'll be able to interact
with a variety of devices,
including proximity tags,
watches, fitness meters, game
controllers, remote controls,
and help devices.
For more details on Bluetooth
Low Energy and using these
APIs in your app, check out
this DevByte from our BLE
expert Fred Chung.
We've also introduced Java
interfaces and native support
for OpenGL 3.0 so games
and other apps with
high-performance 2D and 3D
graphics are now fully
supported by the underlying
graphics hardware.
OpenGL ES 3.0 includes many
improvements, including these,
that support the creation and
complex but efficient graphics
that work across a range of
devices using a single texture
compression format.
There also a number of
enhancements to Android's
media stack, starting with a
modular DRM framework that
makes it easy to integrate DRM
into your preferred streaming
protocols such as MPEG DASH.
The new media DRM class is a
modular solution that separate
DRM from media playback.
So, for example, you could play
back Widevine encrypted
content without having to use
the Widevine media format.
The media DRM APIs should be
used in conjunction with the
Media Codec APIs that were
introduced in Android 4.1,
including media codec for
encoding and decoding your
content, MediaCrypto for
handling encrypted content,
and Media Extractor
for extracting and
demuxing your content.
Support for VP8 encoding is
also now available as
framework and native APIs
for a range of formats.
The APIs include support for
setting target bit rate, rate
controls, selecting frame rates,
token partitioning,
area resilience,
reconstruction, and loop filters.
Back in Android 4.1, the Media
Codec class introduced support
for low-level encoding and
decoding of media, but it
required that it be provided
as a byte buffer array.
In Android 4.3, you can use a
surface as the input to an
encoder, so you can encode
input directly from an
existing video file
while using frames
generated from OpenGL ES.
To use the surface as the input
to an encoder, call
configure on your MediaCodec
object followed by a
callCreateInputSurface to
receive the surface upon which
you can stream your media.
To begin encoding, call start
on the MediaCodec and when
done, call
signalEndOfInputStream to
terminate the encoding before
releasing the surface.
The Media Muxer class enables
multiplexing between an audio
stream and a video stream.
It's designed to work primarily
with MediaCodec, so
you can perform video processing
using MediaCodec
and then save the output
to an MP4 file
using the Media Muxer.
The Media Muxer can also be used
in combination with Media
Extractor to perform media
editing without the need to
encode or decode.
Currently, MP4 is the only
supported output format, and
the Media Muxer supports only
one audio stream and one video
stream at a time.
The first Jelly Bean release
allowed media players to offer
playback controls from remote
control clients, like the lock
screen, ongoing notifications,
and Bluetooth remotes.
This is all done using the
remote control client API.
Now, these applications can also
display playback progress
and handle jumping to
a specific playback
position via scrubbing.
If you're already using the
remote control client APIs,
then you can add support for
scrubbing by enabling the flag
key media position
update using the
setTransportControlFlags
method on the
remote control client.
And this is going to make
the scrubber visible.
Then, implementing both an
onGetPlaybackPositionListener,
overriding the
onGetPlaybackPosition method
to return the current position
of your media, and an
onPlaybackPositionUpdate
listener with an overridden
onPlaybackPositionUpdate method
to listen for a new
time code when the user scrubs
the playback using the remote
control UI.
With these interfaces defined,
you can then set them on your
remote control client by calling
setOnGetPlayback
PositionListener and
setPlaybackPosit
ionUpdateListener.
A new UI automation framework
uses the accessibility service
APIs to support tests that
interact with the device's UI
by inspecting the screen
content and injecting
arbitrary keyboard
and touch events.
You can also perform system UI
actions like hitting the back
button, rotating the screen, and
even taking screenshots.
Best of all, the UI automation
APIs work across application
boundaries.
To get an instance of the
UI automation, call
instrumentation dot
getUIAutomation within your
instrumentation test case.
You can then perform tests by
creating events and injecting
them into the message loop and
confirm the results by
introspecting UI elements.
You do this by obtaining the
root accessibility node of the
UI and searching for the screen
element you want to
inspect, either by
name or by ID.
Execute your test using the
adb am instrument command
specifying the -w flag, package
name, and test runner.
Next up, the Systrace tool has
been improved to make it
easier to provide more
ways to profile the
performance of your app.
You can now collect trace data
from hardware modules, kernel
functions, the Dalvik VM,
including garbage collection,
resource loading and more.
Android 4.3 also introduces
the Trace class with a new
static methods begin section and
end section, which allow
you to define specific parts
of your query to include in
Systrace reports.
So you can get a much more
detailed analysis of where
slowdown occurs within
your app.
There are also new developer
options to help you analyze
performance and spot
rendering issues.
The profile GPU rendering option
lets you visualize your
app's effective frame
rate on screen.
You can choose display profiling
data as on-screen
bar or line graphs with colors
indicating time spent creating
drawing commands--
blue--
issuing the commands--
orange--
and waiting for the commands
to complete--
yellow.
The on-screen graphs are updated
continuously, showing
a graph for each visible
activity as well as the
navigation bar and
notification bar.
A green line highlights the 60
millisecond threshold for
rendering operations, so you can
see your app's effective
frame rate relative
to a 60 FPS goal.
There are also improvements
to internationalization,
including new utilities and APIs
for creating better RTL
strings and psuedo-locales to
make it easier to test your
app's localization.
Accessibility services can now
observe and filter key events,
so they can handle keyboard
shortcuts or provide
navigation in parity with
gesture-based input.
And apps can now define the exit
and entry animation times
used on a window when the
device is rotated.
You can set window properties
to enable jump cut, cross
fade, or standard windows
rotation.
Look for more information on
changes to the UI, including
these animation changes,
from a Chet near you.
Just in time for Android 4.3,
the support package ActionBar
API now, at last,
is available.
Find out all about how to
integrate this critical piece
of the Android design language
into your app from this
DevByte from our very
own Chris Banes.
When we weren't busy launching
new Jelly Bean flavors, we
were busy in our studio.
Ankur is releasing the fourth
part of his five-part series
on making apps beautiful,
this time looking
at performance tuning.
Chet, meantime, returns with the
highly anticipated second
part of his series
on anticipation.
And on "The App Clinic" last
week, I used cricket apps as
an excuse to design my own
version of the perfect sports
tracking app.
My artistic skills are roughly
on a par to the Australian top
order's batting skills, so I
devoted most of my session to
strategies for minimizing
latency while maximizing
battery efficiency.
If your app needs frequent
updates but you don't want to
drain the battery, check
this one out.
Our design advocates will be
taking my amateur marks and
turning them into something
more inspirational in
tomorrow's episode of "Android
Design in Action." As always,
you can go to developers.googl
e.com/live/android to see what
we've got planned for "ADL"
this coming week.
The release of Android 4.3 also
saw a flood of new and
improved apps to Google Play,
including "Beauty and the
Beast" with restricted profile
support, a Runtastic update
that supports Bluetooth Low
Energy, Netflix updated to
provide 1080P HD video, and
games such as "Galaxy on Fire
2," "Monster Shooter 2," "Prince
of Persia," "The
Shadow and the Flame,"
and "Riptide
GP2" from Vector Unit.
We'll be back next week for more
of "What's New in Android
Development." In the meantime,
that's all for our special
"What's New in Android
4.3" edition.
Thanks for watching, and
remember that these sounds
fall into my mind.